you think you can fix me gene you are
not broken
the mind is a fragile thing takes only
the slightest tap to tip it in the wrong
direction
Charles what did you do I had to keep a
stable I protected her from the truth
there's another word for that I came
looking for answers you feel like you
don't belong here you don't they can't
begin to comprehend what you are she's
changing
at what you didn't come here looking for
answers you came here looking for
permission
she's one range
hey miss war coming out of us
gene lost control is she still a Fed
this is sure to hold Charles the world
is on the break I'm sorry I didn't stop
it sooner you're always sorry Charles
and there's always a speech and nobody
cares there still
don't do this
they're right to fear me
I've seen evil
I'm looking at it now
[Applause]
how's it going everyone so we just got
the very first trailer for Dark Phoenix
and for those of you wondering yes it is
just dark Phoenix it is not x-men dark
Phoenix they decided to drop the x-men
from the title so there are a few things
that I took away from this trailer for
starters it looks like it's going to be
part Phoenix force origin story for
about the first 40 seconds we get a
glimpse in the past of young Jean Grey
we see where she got in a car accident
with her parents and we see where she
meets Professor Xavier it's interesting
that they actually don't really mention
much about the Phoenix force in the
trailer so I'm curious to see how
they're going to take this sort of mini
origin story here about the Phoenix
force the next thing I notice is that
this sort of has an x-men The Last Stand
field to it
Charles trying to hide the Phoenix force
from Jean thinking he can control it up
until it finally just becomes too
powerful for even him to control and
eventually it takes over Jean so then we
see this scene where she goes to what
looks like Magneto's base camp not too
sure what happens after x-men apocalypse
but it does look like magneto has set up
a camp here and there are what appears
to be a lot of other mutants around so
maybe this is sort of a refuge for
exposed mutants after the events of
x-men apocalypse so Jean arrives and she
says I came looking for answers but then
in another scene we see magneto tell her
you didn't come here looking for answers
you came here looking for permission
this is probably because it's the
classic difference between Magneto and
Professor Xavier magneto always wants
his pupils and his followers to unleash
their full power and Professor Xavier is
more on the tame side so it seems like
Professor X probably won't let her
explore the true power of the Phoenix
force so she goes to my Nieto because
she knows that he'll be okay with it and
from here on out in the trailer what I
really noticed is this ultimate division
between Magneto and Professor X now
typically there is a fine line between
the two of them but in the past few
movies they've had their differences but
they usually end up coming together at
the end of the
and being on the same side but the tone
of this trailer makes it seem like
there's going to be a true division
between the two of them no going back
and what's really interesting about this
division is that you can see beast is
with Magneto
so it's clearly coming to a point of
choosing between Professor X or Magneto
and another interesting thing about the
trailer is that it didn't show much of
Jessica Chastain's character it
certainly seems like Jean and the
Phoenix force are the real threat in the
movie so maybe she just has a sort of
minor role as a villain who kind of just
eggs on Jean to unleash her full power
another thing that really stood out is
this funeral we can see this grave here
and I'm not too sure who it is but if I
had to guess I would say mystique and
then of course at the end it seems like
the Phoenix force completely takes over
Jean Grey so that's it for the Dark
Phoenix trailer let me know what you all
think about that in the comments below
just a reminder that I'm doing a
giveaway giving away a few copies of
Avengers infinity war on blu-ray some
special edition posters and some special
edition memorabilia all you have to do
to enter is subscribe to my channel like
this video and comment below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero
thank you so much for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]